he still prefers his own style over all
others
Thomas Schmitz has been wearing the same
book for 25 years he designs the clothes
himself and has hardly changed the cuts
he's willing to take a bit more risk
when it comes to fabric I don't know
where I got the idea but we're looking
for things that stand out in the
catalogue we'll set a very British tone
this is for next spring and I'm
imagining a model wearing a boater may
be holding a cricket bat for life behind
crooked schlager I don't say back to the
roots so to speak it's a hearten a
German designing British fashion could
be a Monty Python skit Thomas Smith's
lived in England and studied economics
in Ireland
he's never hidden the fact that he's mad
about everything British he loves flat
jackets made of Scottish tweed they're
placed in just the right setting in the
new catalogue the fabrics are hand-woven
and very durable he has the made in
Turkey in Britain Smith's wife is
responsible for marketing her challenge
is to gain young fans for good old
classic style we've really got to bridge
a gap in the catalogue it can't just be
men in Tweed standing on the lawn of a
typical English manor we've also got to
have more modern urban settings
something like shabby chic savvy 6
August Maude Tomasz Schmidt's opened the
first John Crockett shop in Cologne 28
years ago he designed the label himself
Cross cricket bats a croquet mallet and
tennis racket guarantee a British look
it's Tom on the saleswoman shows him the
latest ties their main customers are men
the suit costs 300 euros that's a
mid-range price in addition to the
ever-present plaids colorful products
are available
Schmidt sells cashmere sweaters in 98 a
man who wears British style does it to
make a point
really wild shirts and ties probably
wouldn't sell here they're for a very
specific market we need to buy them in
London and they're sent to Japan America
and Ireland to a very specific type of
customer buys those kind of things
otherwise British actually stands for
sporty and elegant elegant condition
more than 70% of the customers order
online in addition the firm sends
packages to France and Switzerland
deliveries get dispatched to Britain now
and then to Tomas Schmidt's has focused
on online business for 15 years and
that's guaranteed his survival he used
to have four shops but they were too
expensive the meat and galapiat the
rents are out of control there's a
dolphin bond it keeps getting more and
more expensive we're competing with big
chains that are located there so I
decided to devote more to online
business rather than building up a big
network of branches the new Crockett
collection will be available in autumn
there's a smaller selection for women
they're waiting to see if the new models
appeal to the young to